before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
I don't normally do predictions but I am
going to say right now when Mel bush
first sees Judy got to his doctor she
will declare some variant of well
I see you don't need to get on the
exercise bike anymore
yeah this one like I I try not to do
extra videos uh on here I'm buried in
other stuff and I'm usually more likely
to shift something to a Saturday and
bump it but you know what
we're just going to throw this in as an
extra one lovely for you Bonnie Langford
the actress who portrayed Mel Bush
during both the sixth and seventh
doctor's era in the classic run of
Doctor Who will be returning and will be
featured in the upcoming series along
with shooty gotcha's doctor now not only
has she been confirmed to come back and
to be playing Mel but it is being said
that this is not going to be a small
Cameo like we saw with her and a number
of other companions in say power of the
doctor but a full-on appearance where
she will be helping defeat uh monsters
and just being right alongside the
doctor as she was back in the 80s so
how do I feel about this
well this news comes at an interesting
time for me because on the one hand I
have if you've been following me showing
increasing trepidation about how many
things that are being done going into
rtd's New Era of show running Doctor Who
appeared to mirror what he did with his
initial run when he started knew who and
again not to besmirch that Legacy he did
great stuff but I've been getting
increasingly nervous that this new
series is going to be trying to
recapture what he did back in the
mid-2000s instead of apply new
sensibilities in a new direction under
someone who worked on the show before
because I've said before RTD I do feel
has grown and evolved as a Creator and
as a writer and I want to see what this
version of RTD will do I don't what I
don't want to see is see him recapturing
the old stuff and as things have lined
up even though it's temporary the return
of uh David Tennant and uh Catherine
Tate has me a bit worried the return of
Murray gold to do the music again has me
worried the return of old uh producing
Partners has me worried there are an
increasing number of things that are
just lining up with what he did last
time the the news that they're already
working on spin-offs has me worried now
I have not abandoned hope and I am
certainly going to watch with as much
eagerness as I have but I really wanted
to see something that would make me go
oh well that's different and there has
been some of that the casting of
shooting himself and the images that
we've seen teasing his various looks the
level of dapperness from him I'm getting
a feel of him that does not feel like a
repeat of the characterization of the
doctor there is that and that helps but
I don't want it just to be a different
doctor surrounded by super familiar
stuff top to bottom that feels like it
was lifted out of TV from 15 years ago
but that brings me back to Mal and
Bonnie Langford
on the one hand
this does feel in many ways like a
attempt to repeat what was done with
Sarah Jane Smith when um Elizabeth
sladen was brought back during the
episode School reunion in the second
series which was David Tennant's first
series The Return of a classic companion
having a properly featured role this
potentially could slot into like my
worries of you're just doing the same
stuff again
and I'm gonna say I'm not gonna say that
it's definitely not kind of a little bit
more on that pile
but it's not adding to that pile of
concerns to the degree that I might have
thought it would
couple reasons for that first is Mel is
a very different companion from Sarah
Jane and I don't just mean as far as
characterization goes I mean as far as
fan perception goes
Sarah Jane Smith was a beloved companion
she was one of the best love Companions
of the classic era you know the
conversation for best companions were
people like her Ramana 2. you know
everyone has their individual favorites
but they were frequently in the
conversation uh Ace Jamie you know but
she was up there she was generally
considered among the best so when
bringing Elizabeth sladen back for the
second series that was a lot more of
almost kind of reassuring the older fans
and giving them a massive hit of
nostalgia like remember how great she
was let's give you those memories and
also to give newer fans a reason to
realize something that was great about
the older show
the fan assessment of Mal is not quite
the same while I do think that people
have softened on her a bit with time Mel
has generally been at the lower end
definitely the lower half of Assessments
for Companions and that's not really
Bonnie langford's faults the character
well flatly it said uh it's been said
that she was cast largely for her scream
and they did not miss opportunities to
have her scream a lot and the character
was pushy she was an exercise in that
she's very much a product of the 80s and
a lot of it hasn't dated well and not
even in terms of like ooh problematic
but just in terms of cultural points of
reference like wow that is that's super
of its time so bringing back Mel doesn't
feel like quite the same ooh Nostalgia
as before it feels like it might be more
of an opportunity to take a less
appreciated companion and do something
to get people to appreciate her better
which brings me to the other thing that
is serendipitous in terms of timing so I
had in the past seen as at least one
story with Mel in it now I've seen I'd
seen two like historically until very
recently I'd seen time on the Ronnie and
I'd seen dragon fire and she did not
leave a great impression in either one
she actually didn't leave much of an
impression at all in Dragonfire and she
brought me the wrong way big time in
time in the Ronnie but recently
um I have watched trial of a Time Lord
I'm releasing those reviews over in the
break room of Geeks that's my secondary
Channel subscribe over there if you
haven't already and uh I have now seen
her introductory story where we first
see her with the sixth doctor you know
what
she's pretty good in it and so what I've
come to appreciate is the stuff that I
uh that I'd seen prior to that of Bonnie
Langford and the part of Mel is a
character that wasn't great
was not intrinsic to the character or to
the actress not to mention the fact that
she's got almost 40 years worth of
getting better and more comfortable as
an actor and she is a fairly well
regarded one at this at this point on
television and on stage so even if you
didn't think much of her at the time I
have little reason to doubt that she has
honed her craft in the decades since but
even just going back to that first
appearance
she is shockingly solid given what I
knew the general opinion of her was and
also my own opinion and some of the
stuff she appeared in later that I'd
seen like no there's a lot more
potential to this character than was
ever realized in the original show now
some of that slack has been picked up by
big finish audio Adventures they're very
good at picking up the underappreciated
uh aspects of story or characters from
the classic era and polishing them up to
a brand new mirror Sheen I mean the
sixth doctor himself that was a huge
part of what they did but that is
something that's very much devoted fans
you're more casual fans your fans
focused on the TV series
don't know that and heck a lot of them
probably don't know Mel at all if they
came in with new who but even a lot of
classic fans haven't seen a Redemption
for the character of Mel that's gone on
in big finish because it's ancillary
media not everybody takes it in this is
a chance to bring that more front and
center and no that's not me saying oh
and they'll directly take cues from Big
finish like they might they might not
but there's an opportunity to do
something similar on a bigger stage by
giving the good parts of this character
by bringing her back and having her and
habit this character wants more with a
new doctor and it gets me excited in a
way that the general idea of repeating
the beat of classic error companion
comes back into the modern setting you
know that just on paper without knowing
who it was that feels like it should be
getting me nervous again like repeating
that too and again I'm not gonna say
there's none of that but it's pretty
clamped down because of who they opted
to do it with
because I already kind of feel like Mel
is a companion kind of got the short end
of the stick she was better than she got
and just
seeing an opportunity to take a not as
beloved character and do something
interesting with them as opposed to just
bringing back a beloved character and be
like hey look it's them again it just
feels like a commitment to do more or at
the very least if you're going to not be
lazy about it it kind of Demands that
you do more
it's also a nice
um acknowledgment and confirmation that
people
whatever you think of the chipmilera
there is a lot of divisiveness about it
and I think a lot of people whether you
like the chiminal era or not anyone who
is not a complete uh close-minded
diversity is the death of all things
kind of uh person if you're not part of
the anti-wolf crowd then even if you
didn't like Chipmunks era you may have
shared my some of my concerns that some
of what the chipmil era attempted to do
which were solid ideas but may not have
been executed that well would be
something that the show would now be
afraid to do because it was done during
an era that was not as successful as far
as the viewing numbers go and whether
you like it or not that's
actually true so I'm not trying to rile
anybody up but one of the things that it
did towards the very end with the power
of the doctor was bring in a number of
classic commands I mean we had all the
ones in the meeting at the very end but
prior to that giving a highlight to
Tegan and to Ace and those were also
some of the highlights of that special
but it would be very easy to throw the
baby out with the bath water and just
have it be a situation of well an era
that wasn't successful did this let's
not do it again let's not risk that
having been part of the reason why that
era wasn't successful and seeing
um a character like Mel be brought back
and put in a place of prominence as is
being indicated that is a reassurance to
me that at the very least RTD whether or
not the the uh anyone else involved with
the BBC as a whole is like this I don't
know but at the very least RTD is not
going to look at General Zar and go like
there's nothing you know we're doing in
fact we need to avoid even looking like
we're doing anything similar
honestly he's probably largely
disregarding for the most part and he's
got to do his own thing and whether it
resembles something done uh by chipmunk
or not he probably doesn't care or at
least that's what I hope his approach is
because that would have been my advice
and recommendation to him not that he
would have asked me for advice although
you know Russell uh my contact
information is down in the description
so if you want to hire me as a consult
I'll work cheap
only only for Doctor Who though you want
to hire me for other stuff we'll talk
Fair rates but oh I'm
just whoring myself out now aren't I
dignity what's that
um but in any case it it it's a little
bit of a relief in that way because you
know seeing and and having known that
immediately after Judy Whitaker they
um brought in another male doctor while
I am very excited for shudigatwa don't
mistake me for saying otherwise there
was an inherent ugh
is there going to be a gut reaction to
we can never have the doctor be a woman
again because that Arrow wasn't as
successful or as universally loved as we
wanted so don't risk it and you know
that sort of fear and that mentality can
snowball to any of the other stuff that
that error either tried to do or um that
felt like
um things that should have worked but
for some reason didn't you know like
bringing back
um older people and older Companions and
and whatnot but to get that assurance
that this new RTD era RTD2 is not going
to shy away from an idea just because it
resembles something done fairly recently
by the chipmilera
that helps and like again I doubt that's
part of the actual calculus that went
into uh the decision that was made but
then that's good they should be
factoring that in just do what you think
makes a good story
so yeah
despite my initial impressions of Bonnie
Langford as Mel not having been great
knowing her reputation knowing that this
is a repeat of a beat that uh RTD did
before despite all that
I'm surprisingly excited for the idea of
Mel coming back
especially just because Mel's not a
character that immediately slots into
like a clear-cut post-doctor life like
Sarah Jane becoming a journalist total
sense makes absolute sense uh Ace you
know just kind of going about being Ace
and causing a certain degree of chaos
yeah yeah that tracks you know some of
that stuff that feels very natural I'm
curious
as to what Mel's post-doctor life was it
doesn't feel as clear-cut because again
she's a little bit of an outlier and a
little bit less beloved and very of her
time so like one would assume she's not
still jumping around like an aerobics
nut like she was 40 years ago so what is
she up to
I'll be happy to see and find out
Bonnie Langford returning his mouth what
are your thoughts on this whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills enables me to do this as my living
even if you can't help me out that way
like share subscribe links to other
things I do are down in the description
so feel free to check all those out but
don't worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore
to rock the thing that goes doink in the
anime Ruth Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen Leo
the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]